that was disappointing man who jesse
yeah man just telling us you're not
suicidal like that like come on bro
kill yourself please yes i had enough
you're done i had enough
he faked the hate crime he didn't kill
someone i wish you'd have really
committed suicide how about that
i had enough of this guy i mean that
would be kind of fire
yeah right yeah something i mean it will
be kind of funny i'm not suicidal like
the government's gonna take you out yeah
are you [ __ ] kidding me bro yeah
you're a threat to nothing
he could be as big as epstein
maybe
in some in some abstract way i'm sure he
could connect a few dots you know
he's confident he's a confident guy yeah
he is a confident guy he is bro he
planned this whole [ __ ] elaborate
[ __ ] and really thought he was going
to get away with it yeah but he could
have though i feel like it'd be so easy
to get away with
yeah i feel like it was shadowly done
right like how easy it is to get away
with the hate crime probably pretty easy
yeah
like just
i mean the way that he designed it was
horrible yeah just actually get beat up
it was during a winter vortex yeah in
chicago yeah like he like he said it was
like mega guys that came up to him and
then the two guys that he actually paid
to do it he like paid them with a
personal check yeah like he like left a
paper trip like it was just horrendous
yeah everybody like he himself or no
they went to the hardware store to go
get it yeah to go get the stuff and also
the bleach thing like everything like
clearly he hasn't studied hate crime
enough
because like white people aren't trying
to make black people white yeah like the
bleach thing doesn't make sense like
that's not like racist white people's
dream they're not like seeing black
people and they're like how can we make
them white right
right like so you're not gonna also like
just pouring bleach you have to worry
about it getting on you and it's just
like it's just messy it's like super
messy right like everything about it
poorly designed uh the fact that when
the cops come like he still has the
noose on like you wouldn't take that off
first like
like you get home from a long day at
work immediately
you lose your time right i watch my dad
do it every single day working hard
every single day come back losing the
time maybe take the tie off yeah you're
at a wedding first thing ty's loosened
right
fraternity party the tie's on for some
event and then immediately it's around
your head or something like that but
he's still got the [ __ ] tie on he's
still in the bleach you're like
everything about it was so poorly
planned and the guy's been in hollywood
like that's what i assume though i think
he's a good actor and i think the best
actors think their whole life's a movie
oh i don't know dude
i'm with you on this i think he still
is in it like he's in his soap opera no
that's right yeah that's what i mean
like what makes him a good actor is the
fact that he believes that he's the main
character in life nobody yelled cut i
bet if you just yell cut
[Laughter]
lee daniels comes in and just goes cut
immediately goes okay and then yeah okay
okay that was great uh judge
hypothetically you were really yeah yeah
yeah you have to say the word
anchorman
i respect you
i respect you judge
but i am not suicidal
what does that mean
what does that even mean love it i
respect you i respect your decision but
i'm not suicidal i'm rooting for him yep
all of a sudden i'm starting to [ __ ]
root for him yes and i'm like what lies
do we tell ourselves kim thinks she
works hard
and she believes it
why can't he believe he didn't do that
how many things do we just believe oh
yeah you told me that that's actually a
very helpful trick i started doing that
what's that you said just tell yourself
what happened in the past and then
create a new reality and then and then
believe it yep that works
100 that's just fire dude mark thought i
lied to him about a kid having cancer
dude this kid is [ __ ] warped
this is a perfect story it was a perfect
story dude all right so basically i was
telling shows i was having a really bad
week i was telling some of you guys and
i was really going through it i was
having a hard time i was like man i just
don't know you know my purpose in life
blah blah blah and he was like mark
do you wanna know what your purpose is i
was just just today i was in soho with
dov i didn't say we want to know your
purposes but i said let me tell you
something that happened today can you
let him tell him
and i'm at this coffee shop with tub and
this little kid he runs up to me he's
you know 13 years old he's he says
andrew andrew schultz i just beat cancer
and i was listening to flagrant two the
whole time and i'm so grateful that you
guys make me laugh thank you so much and
then he flew away like a dove
i didn't say it and i dropped my knees i
cried i converted christianity i said
thank you jesus let me bask in your
light that's what he said that was the
whole story
but no it was just the first part of
story but i heard it and i was like wow
that's an amazing story thank you so
much for telling me and i was thinking
about later it was like that's such a
perfect story that's an amazing story
what would you tell your buddy that's
like having a hard time would it be more
perfect if it happened to you [ __ ]
it didn't happen to me
do you remember the kid
stop it are you kidding me you're being
a dick are you kidding me you're getting
into this yesterday and you were like
you're being a [ __ ] right i told you
this yesterday and you're like no it's
true
it was fake listen ben right now who's
listening ben is it real or ben and you
were with a woman or i don't know if she
was your mom i don't know who she was
but you came up to me outside of ame
this is when we went to him what did he
have to do and there was a kid that came
up to me
yes
thank you
except i didn't hear what he said i was
focused on a girl in line fair fair
enough still but you focus on his mom no
little kid no no this is true this is
true
he was a kid he came up and he said
listen to flagrant two and he'd watch
the clips and it was all throughout the
time he was in the hospital i think he
said he was in hospital for three years
and and we really kept his spirits up
and he just recently was announced as
cancer-free teenager and that's a
beautiful thing well why don't you
believe him it was just such a perfect
story you're going through a hard time
you call everybody he's like well you
know you actually what a dick i'm just
saying
piece of [ __ ] i'm trying to give you
some light tabasco it's an amazing story
yeah life is about
you story those stories that's what's
completely plausible you didn't write it
down that was the issue you didn't write
it down
right now i guess uh no you didn't write
it down no you told it to me on the
phone yeah the original bible wasn't
written down yeah why was [ __ ]
talking all day yeah oral history i
don't know that's that's dicey all i'm
saying is that's a real story ben dm
mark to let him know shout out to you
ben appreciate you thank you for
listening i'm glad we could help you
through that difficult time yeah now
what did that have to do with what we
were talking about i forget oh the you
faked the i love crime i think i love
crime yeah the opposite
i didn't fake him he did he was a
nigerian man that came up to you yeah
and he was like hey man i love flaker
two i have
cancer specifically nobody else in the
shower
[Laughter]
we lie to ourselves all the time and we
believe these lies all the time easier
weapons of mass destruction yes
is that not worse
than
jesse
is that not worse than just slightly
worse slightly worse
nobody died with jesse jesse did it to
himself it was a self-inflicted but he
almost like couldn't go to jail say
again like i'm pretty sure he had to
they were gonna go to jail eventually
okay
wait what wait wait wait not nigerian
wait what happened not the nigerians oh
wow yeah these other guys they like he
had to do like a lineup and pick people
out and he was like i think it was them
yo they deserve to be in jail why
because they were in on
hey you know what isn't it time white
people took the fall for something black
people dude
hey that's the justice system working
this way that's the oj but the other way
yes